MARTIN OMANDER: Cloud
developer communities
are groups of like-minded
cloud developers
who get together on a regular
basis and teach each other,
learn from each other on new
cloud developer technologies.
AMANDA CAVALLARO: When you
attend one of the Google Cloud
community meet-ups,
you just can talk
to people about what you're
doing, your new projects,
and you also have the
chance to talk to experts
and learn from them.
DEMI BEN-ARI: You
can also create
some kind of communication
between different Cloud GDGs
all around the world.
Like we're doing Tel Aviv
together with London.
It's amazing the impact that
you can give to the developer
community.
VIKRAM TIWARI: As the
communities evolve
and the products evolve, our
topics also evolve with time,
including more details
or more fundamentals
of as new things get launched.
JIRAYUT NIMSAENG: We have people
from Google sharing experience
with [INAUDIBLE] from the GCP.
ALLINE OLIVEIRA: It's
very important for me
to starting something
specific for Google Cloud
because it's something new in
Brazil that is very diverse.
And it's going to be different.
VIKRAM TIWARI: Most
of our activities
are hands-on, where
you come in, and both
of us and our assistants go
together through the code,
and we run through exercises
and get good results.
ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Google Cloud Platform
has been enjoying
amazing growth recently.
They give us amazing feedback
on what the products really
should be, trying to
make sure we address
the market as best as possible.
[MUSIC PLAYING]